now let's go to some other reactions
from people
to the blockbuster claims from bob
woodward and robert costa including at
the top of the list that a chairman of
the joint chiefs general mark milley was
so afraid trump was so unhinged in in
milly's eyes that millie was afraid
trump might nuke someone and started
putting in place all of these safeguards
let's go piece by piece this first
interview was stephen moore a former
economic advisor to trump appearing with
neil cavuto
and
in responding to the revelations of the
book
moore again refuses to even say trump
lost the election like he's still on
that
this guy is pathetic and no pushback
from neil cavuto i think that those
questions really need to be asked about
joe biden in his mental capacity right
now but no i never saw that from donald
trump i do think in a few days after the
election he had a hard time coming to
grips with the results yeah that that's
the understatement of the century and i
think he's obviously still uh doesn't
believe that he lost but
no i don't i do not believe he was ever
in a state of incapacitation where the
country was ever in danger
do you believe he lost the election
i believe there's a lot i believe we'll
never know the real answer to that i do
believe there was a lot of voter fraud
but i also believed you would you
couldn't unscramble that egg and once
those votes were counted there was no
that way they were going to be
overturned and we'll see whether you
know look i do believe there's a high
likelihood right now that donald trump
will run for president in 20.
do you understand what he did there he
is so they are
first of all
this is such a simple question did
donald trump win or lose the election
and the answer is he lost
and you can not like joe biden and you
can say listen neil
the people spoke and it wasn't even that
close joe biden won and that's it they
still can't even acknowledge that
they may never acknowledge it they're
not seemingly getting over this
but moore actually goes a step further
and says
it may be an unknowable thing we may
never know who actually won the election
which is like an extra little wrinkle to
the thing which is i'm i'm not saying
trump definitely won but i'm certainly
not saying trump lost
but i'm adding on to it we won't know
which is exactly how these people will
cling to the belief that maybe trump won
when you start hearing people say it's
unknowable it's you are basically saying
it's a matter of opinion it's a we we
don't know we will never know it's a
scrambled egg you can't unscramble an
egg
um
and and so it justifies people
having the opinion that trump actually
won when it is an empirically knowable
thing okay here's a couple here's rand
paul
commenting on the mark milley report but
if it is true absolutely immediately
needs to be removed we we have elections
we can't have generals overturning
elections that we've always criticized
in authoritarian regimes where the
military takes over this is very very
dangerous and uh if this happened milly
needs to be immediately removed of his
command
we can't have generals overturning
elections we can't have authoritarian
reversals of our elections
that's exactly what donald trump wanted
in terms of mike pence
and may even have been thinking about
how the military could be used to that
end but rand paul says oh we can't have
millie controlling election and then
lastly here's another just off-the-wall
reaction to this here's laura ingraham
in responding to the revelations about
trump and nukes and mark milley
downplaying the riots of january 6th
again democrats and trump haters have
clung to the events of january 6 with a
white-knuckled death grip
they claim a riot that the capitol
police should have been prepared for was
actually an insurrection the shortest in
world history by the way it was an
attempted insurrection laura please
but today we learned the truth there was
indeed an insurrection being planned
around that time in washington but it
took place at the pentagon and its chief
architect was general mark milley can
you imagine
the insurrection was mark millie's and
of course
that's not true
but they don't know where to go with
this stuff you've got two reactions
basically
taking place to these revelations about
trump and the nukes in china
one side is
it's all lies
all the interviews
the transcripts the records the fact
checking there it's just they are all
all all lies and you can't believe any
of it the other side is it's all true
and it's treason by mark millie well
guys you're going to have to pick one
which is it are they all lies or are
they real but it's treason by mark
milley figure it out because i'm
starting to have a hard time keeping up
let's take a quick break we'll be back
after this with so much more